[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon if you'd like to help
me make more political content consider
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the end of 2019 people were
thoroughly fed up with the 2010s and
ready to start a new decade on the right
foot 2020 rolled around and well it
hasn't gone great so far over the past
two decades a general sense of
dissatisfaction with the status quo has
been building up in wealthy capitalist
countries including the United States as
most things do it started off fairly
quiet a bit of push back on the Iraq war
after the initial surge of support a
loss of faith in the system after the
financial crash of 2008 Occupy Wall
Street black lives matter a
self-proclaimed Democratic Socialist
coming incredibly close to securing the
Democratic nomination for the 2016
presidential election increasing
pushback on police brutality intense
criticism of how a for-profit health
care system handles a pandemic and the
topic for this video the genesis of a
huge wave of new left media from print
magazines to podcasts to Academy Award
winning movies the left is seeing a real
resurgence in popularity
tonight we riot is perhaps the most
recent example and I think it's an
important one produced by the games
division of means TV which bills itself
as the world's first anti-capitalist
streaming service tonight we riot takes
a different approach to getting its
political message across whereas many
other games satirize capitalism and it's
ill effects tonight we riot is a blatant
condemnation of capitalism and more
importantly it's available on more than
just PC you can currently get a game
that advocates the destruction and
replacement of the capitalist system on
the famously family-friendly Nintendo
switch this is a big deal for people who
share the sentiment that capitalism has
outlived its usefulness most people
don't want to spend hours reading some
dense tome on leftist political theory
but they'll gladly play a fun retro side
scroller and consume a similar message
this is indicative of both the problem
the left has faced for decades and the
solution that has long been more
effectively embraced by the political
right political theory doesn't have to
be boring and overly complex look at
Prager you Dennis Prager personal
propaganda outlet pumps out easily
digestable right-wing notions with
appealing graphics and features
welcoming seemingly knowledgeable hosts
and it's earned them almost two and a
half million subscribers the left waists
huge amounts of time debunking the trash
Prager you puts out which none of their
viewers will see or believe and yet to
my knowledge there's no left equivalent
of this very successful model Prager you
has plagued YouTube since 2009 11 years
now and the left still doesn't have a
comparable
annele that's quite a head start of
course YouTube is home to plenty of
excellent leftist content creators but
there are very few channels you could
mention to say your parents or
conservative friends and have them know
who you're talking about
everybody knows Prager you regardless of
age or political bent but while the left
does like a YouTube icon where it has
excelled in recent years is in other
forms of media podcasts in particular
have seen a huge upswing in leftist
content current affairs the trill Billie
Workers Party know your enemy and the
Michael Brooks show to name just a few
and of course the top-grossing podcast
on all of patreon Chapo Trap House all
of these podcasts have cropped up within
the last five years the oldest being
Chapo which began in the run-up to the
2016 election you'd be hard-pressed to
find a person on the Left who's not at
least aware of chapo but the same isn't
true if you expand beyond the extremely
online sphere of millennial leftists
despite being the top grossing podcast
on patreon with over 36,000 patrons they
still pale in comparison to the cultural
penetration achieved by someone like Joe
Rogan who regularly gets millions of
views on YouTube and nearly as many
downloads through various podcast
hosting sites Chapo averages between 150
and 200 thousand downloads per episode
of course Rogan has been running his
show since 2009 so again big head start
part of the reason for Joe Rogan's
incredible popularity is the fact that
he acts as a sort of sounding board for
ideas across the spectrum some
reasonable and many absurd or outright
dangerous he doesn't shy away from
having controversial figures like Alex
Jones on his show but presents himself
impartially enough to have earned a
reputation as a neutral third party who
just wants to talk about different ideas
think of Rogan what you will his show
has proven incredibly successful and
it's a format many other podcasts have
tried to emulate to varying degrees of
success
the new batch of leftist podcast by
comparison are generally fairly niche
Chapo is a refuge for the self professed
dirtbag left the people who aren't
afraid to use course or biting humor to
degrade opponents know your enemy is
specifically about understanding the
American conservative movement the trill
Billy's offer an Appalachian leftist
perspective and current affairs offers a
slightly broader assortment of left
commentary on politics and culture none
of them are guest driven like the Joe
Rogan experience though they all
sometimes bring guests on their shows
with Michael Brooks probably doing so
most frequently whereas each of these
podcasts has their areas of expertise
where Joe Rogan has the advantage is his
everyman appeal he doesn't bill himself
as an expert
anything except maybe MMA and generally
just tries to be that guy who's
interested in everything and fun enough
to talk about all of it without leaving
the listener confused by insider jargon
anyone can turn on his show and feel
like they're on equal footing with the
host I'm not suggesting that the left
should try to emulate this format I'm
not convinced another show will ever
have the broad appeal of the Joe Rogan
experience simply because he's been
doing the show for so long and
essentially has a monopoly on that
corner of the podcast world but in
podcasts just as with YouTube the left
adopting a more accessible and welcoming
brand of politics is crucial to their
success the post-2015 batch of left
podcasts is definitely a step in the
right direction one surprising area in
which the left has found significant
success is with traditional print
publishing both magazines and books
books have always been a haven for
political theory of all stripes but to
build a new and successful print
operation in an era when the world was
convinced print was dead is pretty
impressive take Jacobin magazine for
example founded in 2010 by Bhaskar
Sankara then a 21 year old college
student Jack had been targeted America's
socialists a group that was even smaller
and less organized then than it is today
on paper it was a horrible idea
Anish quarterly print magazine targeting
a group of people on the fringe of
American discourse but it worked
Jacobin found its audience the content
resonated with an underrepresented group
and its circulation quickly grew today
Jacobin has a print circulation of
50,000 people and a monthly web audience
of over 2 million visitors by combining
smart left his commentary with beautiful
design elements Jacobin has managed to
fill an important role in left
publishing this is socialist content
that's pretty enough to display on your
coffee table or bookshelf and maybe
spark a conversation with friends or
family following jacobins success
Nathan J Robinson a PhD student at the
time decided to launch his own
publication in 2015 to his surprise
there wasn't an existing magazine called
current affairs so he jumped at the
opportunity to take a name that was
inviting and uncontroversial once again
in the face of a print journalism
landscape hostile to newcomers this one
succeeded originally a crowdfunded
operation and now reliant on
subscription revenue current affairs
doesn't run advertisement or filler
content and they avoid obscure political
jargon this is absolutely critical in
reaching those people who are unfamiliar
with leftist thought in my opinion the
current affairs magazine and podcast
both strike the right balance between
important critical thoughts and joyful
whimsy that makes leftist thought
appealing and inspiring rather than
stodgy and
pressing socialism definitely has an
image problem in America
so by normalizing leftist literature
with appealing modern design and joyful
language where appropriate left
magazines have made great strides and
chipping away at the socialist or angry
depressed loser stereotype besides
magazines radical book publishers have
had quite a renaissance as well
Haymarket books founded in 2001 was
listed on Publishers Weekly's
fast-growing independent publishers list
in both 2017 and 2018 and offers some of
the best leftist literature currently
available as an independent and
nonprofit operation Haymarket takes
pride in printing books that traditional
risk-averse publishers wouldn't touch
the result is a vibrant representation
of the entire spectrum of leftist
thought with authors from diverse
backgrounds and in genre as varied as
biography political theory and poetry
one of the coolest things about
Haymarket in my opinion is their book
club it's a subscription service that
costs around 30 bucks a month which not
only helps sustain a radical independent
publisher but also gives you some
serious value you'll get every single
new book they publish both in physical
and ebook form as well as 50% off all of
their existing catalog and a print copy
of every book in their historical
materialism and studies and critical
Social Sciences series I'm sure this
sounds like I'm sponsored by Haymarket
books or something but I really just
appreciate they exist but publisher in
America dedicated to leftist
perspectives that's pretty cool I'd be
remiss if I didn't also mention verso
books they've been around since 1970
then known as new left books so they
don't fall into the category of the new
wave of popular left media but they like
Haymarket offer a huge selection of
radical works and their cover art is
always really eye-catching verso is
currently the largest radical publisher
in the english-speaking world and they
have a seriously impressive catalogue
divided into helpful categories they
also run great sales quite frequently so
needless to say I have a lot of verso
books on my shelf in case you can't tell
I'm a huge fan of both verso and
Haymarket and I think what they're doing
is so important having these resources
where you can go and find books from a
leftist perspective on just about any
topic is incredibly helpful both for
educating yourself and to help introduce
friends to left his thought I'll put a
link to both in the description below as
well as to all the other media I
mentioned in this video
one final category where the Left has
found a foothold in recent years is more
traditional media film and streaming
services means TV the first worker-owned
anti-capitalist streaming service
launched in February of 2020 founded by
Naomi Burton and Nick Hayes the team
behind AOC
viral campaign video means TV had one
simple goal provide a home for
post-capitalist video content with no
advertisements no venture capital money
and no corporate backers a streaming
service owned operated and beholden to
average people Hayes says our biggest
criticism of entertainment broadly is
the pervasiveness of advertising and
venture capital and shareholders who
have significant investments in things
like defense or natural gas and oil we
think that those same people creating
our entertainment is wrong it's a good
point and one that most of us don't
often think about when streaming
services have a vested interest in the
profitability of say the oil and gas
industry or the military-industrial
complex we shouldn't be surprised when
we get shows like Jack Ryan and very
rarely anything critical of those
industries when our entire world down to
the shows and movies we watch in our
free time is shaped by those who would
maintain the status quo we end up living
in a little propaganda bubble
commercials depict happy young couples
and expensive houses movies are full of
positively framed US imperialism
we're being served a version of the
world that doesn't reflect the lived
realities of most of the population
means TV is just one step towards
breaking down the facade of the shining
city on a hill
it's a sleek well presented service that
offers everything from feature-length
documentaries to morning news shows and
not a single dollar of their funding
comes from corporate interests by
breaking into the streaming video game
the left now has one more claim to
modern legitimacy but even more
important than streaming video is the
crown jewel of the visual arts
big-budget film while there's been no
shortage of Hollywood and independent
movies that dance around the subject of
class poverty or capitalism in general
we've seen a promising uptick in
explicitly anti-capitalist cinema in
recent years perhaps the most well known
and arguably the most important of these
are the works of bong joon-ho his films
including oak just snowpiercer and
parasite have garnered critical acclaim
and a worldwide appeal his most recent
work parasite won four Oscars including
Best Picture making it the first
non-english language film to win the
coveted prize bong attributes the film's
success to its Universal message saying
compared to all my other films parasite
in particular I think is the most
universal story and no matter where at
screens which country or festival the
audience responds has been pretty
similar I think that's because while on
the surface the film features very
Korean characters and details in the end
it's as if we're all living in this one
country of capitalism the acclaimed
director is known for his film centering
class struggle and inequality with
films being more subtle than others and
with the Netflix adaptation of
snowpiercer not being very subtle at all
the tagline is literally class war but I
think regardless of the manner in which
bong and other filmmakers choose to
deliver their message the fact that
leftist ideas are making it onto the big
screen and winning Academy Awards is a
huge victory while the president may not
have enjoyed the film parasite has
earned worldwide praise and it's not
hard to see why it features a universal
message of living in a terribly unequal
society and shows how a change in
material circumstances can deeply affect
and change a person in a very short time
it's funny it's beautifully shot and it
features some of the best acting I've
seen in recent movies the fact that it
can do all that and deliver a message
that resonates with people around the
world is frankly astonishing the
presence of radical ideas on the silver
screen is a huge step in the right
direction because it will help people of
all backgrounds develop an understanding
of the reality of existence under
capitalism the film's don't have to be
depressing diatribes on inequality they
can be action-packed thrillers on
bizarre sci-fi trains they can be dark
comedies they can be coming-of-age
stories and they can still get the
message across
probably more effectively than dense
political theory books can in 2020 if
there are two things that the write does
better than the left their unity and
visibility the political actors of the
right have long understood that they
need to offer a unified message with
simple core pillars that can be easily
distilled to win people over America is
freedom immigrants are bad poor people
are lazy corporations benefit everyone
these are simple ideas that anyone can
understand the left by contrast is prone
to infighting over all sorts of topics
some important but many frivolous who
cares how Nathan J Robinson dresses who
cares if chapo fans tweet snake emojis
at elected officials the closest the
left has come to offering a unified
platform is the push for Medicare for
all everyone in America should be able
to see a doctor without going bankrupt
that's easy to understand and it's an
idea just about everybody can get behind
regardless of political leaning these
core tenets shouldn't be hard to develop
it'll just take a little more
cooperation between podcasts tans
visibility on the other hand will be a
bit more difficult America has had at
least four decades of entrenched
right-wing media operations and they've
done an incredible job of shifting the
political conversation completely onto
the right side of the spectrum if the
left is to see any real success it must
develop platforms that can become
household names and offer a compelling
alternative to the
prevailing right-wing worldview the left
has the counterproductive habit of
deciding to start countless new
operations instead of backing the
already existing ones that could use the
support
why have thirty bad versions of the DSA
when the DSA already exists sure you
might not agree with them on every
single detail but it's the largest
socialist organization in the United
States and it'll have a lot more
influence than the United Greater North
Texas area a narco communist radical
Workers Party ever will that being said
the establishment of high-profile media
operations like means TV is a great move
now the left has its own streaming
service let's support them and spread
the word
make it a household name Hulu just kind
of existed for a while until suddenly
everybody was watching their content the
same can be true of means TV but only if
they have the funds to develop quality
original content the surge of
anti-capitalist films is a promising
sign too with one movie bong joon-ho is
able to catapult leftist talking points
onto the world stage take advantage of
that recommend it to your friends and
family talk about it afterwards help
grow the visibility of leftist ideas
while the left media landscape is still
comparatively small just look how much
it's grown in the past five years if you
had told me ten years ago that I would
have dozens of socialist podcasts and
YouTube channels to choose from thriving
leftist magazines to read and that
big-budget movies would explicitly
criticize the capitalist system all
within a decade I wouldn't have believed
you the resurgence of left media is real
it's modern its appealing and its timely
so anytime you're feeling down about the
state of the world remember that more
and more people are coming together to
try to change it and they need our
support if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more like it consider
subscribing to stay up to date with my
latest episodes if you hated it go ahead
and drop a thumbs down and if you really
want to help support my channel I
recently started a patreon which you can
find at patreon.com slash second thought
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week